after weeks at Sea the desperate journey
of four Nigerian migrants to reach the
shores of Europe has come to an end
except this isn't Europe
they somehow landed in the Southeastern
Port City of Victoria in Brazil all the
way across the Atlantic Ocean from
Africa
do you know where you are I said no and
they said
that was a first and they said this is
Brazil I said wow this is Brazil
I made it to Brazil I'm happy
the four men say they took on the
perilous Voyage to escape economic
hardship and political instability back
home in Nigeria they stayed perched in
the cramped space above the rudder of a
container ship dangerously close to the
propeller
looping a fishnet around the rudder and
tying themselves to it provided
stability
experience for me
I've been a first time I've never tried
that before but because I already made
up my mind to leave
so I just some of the courage and about
then it's not easy
you know
shaking you know I was so scared
how we're here in Brazil rights groups
say cases like this highlight how many
migrants risk everything for the chance
of a better life before I came here I
was homeless
no home you know my family my wife is
staying in another place where I am
staying my children you know so we also
have to make up my mind and um
two of the migrants have returned to
Nigeria while the others have applied
for asylum in Brazil for them their
InterContinental Voyage is over
but the pursuit to find a better life
continues Imran alahan Al Jazeera
foreign